Girl scouting changes girls' lives in more ways than you can imagine.
It begins when a girl makes a promise to live by the Girl Scout law.
Through its strong timeless values,...
...the girl scout law guides how girls relate to other girl scouts,...
...family, community, and the planet.
School prepares you for your career, but Girl Scouts prepares you for life...
...very real and practical skills for the 21st century.
They're learning critical thinking skills.
They're learning decision-making skills, and project planning skills,...
...and communication skills, and working as a team.
I can do anything I put my mind to.
What girl scouting does better than any other organization...
...has helped girls discover their innate potential to lead.
...and to become comfortable taking on leadership roles.
Since we're older, we get to do more hands-on experience and plan our own meetings.
We build strong, positive women who will be the leaders of tomorrow.